i'm going to start today with the the
prototypical story really that is an
objectively important story to
understand what's going on in the
economy
and that almost no one cares about and
almost no one will watch or engage with
but it doesn't matter it's actually an
important story so we're going to start
with it and the story is that the
federal reserve has raised interest
rates by what's called sometimes 50
basis points or half a percent when they
say 50 what they mean is
0.50 percent this is the biggest
increase in 22 years since the year 2000
and so much of what's going on today
that is flippantly mentioned in in so
many of these 2022 debates that you can
tell the candidates don't really
understand comes down to understanding
what is the impact of raising raising or
lowering the federal funds rate and so
that's what we're going to talk about
and before i get into the details
yesterday we watched and we live
streamed the 2022
pennsylvania republican senate primary
debate this is the one with mehmet oz
and dave mccormick and carla sands and
kathy barnett etc
bartos i think is the fifth guy now i'm
actually remembering their names and
they were asked all of them asked about
inflation and balancing the budgets and
the economy and so many different things
and all five of them expressed no
knowledge whatsoever of how these basic
tools that are available to different uh
government entities work with the
exception of at one point mehmet oz
mentioned
raising the rate to lower inflation and
that was true but then he moved on and
went beyond it so let's jump into the
details and then we'll explain what's
going on
yahoo finance report
fed raises interest rates 0.5 percent
largest move since the year 2000 good
um this is the short-term interest rate
this is an effort to tamp down on the
inflationary pressures weighing on
americans the central bank suggests that
it will further raise borrowing costs
throughout this year as it attempts to
undo its pandemic era easy money
policies
uh the policy setting federal open
market committee also detailed plans on
unwinding its nearly nine trillion
dollar balance sheet
the raising of rates a half a percent is
the most aggressive increase in a single
meeting since may of 2000 over the last
two decades the fed has opted to raise
interest rates in increments of a
quarter of a percent only
so
let's talk about this what how how does
the the rate goes up
and inflation goes down how does that
work well
when you raise the federal funds rate
you make it more expensive for banks to
borrow money
when it's more expensive for banks to
borrow money
they in turn make it more expensive for
people like you and me and businesses to
borrow money when it's more expensive
for us to borrow money we do less
borrowing and when you see the ways in
which this is impactful it will start to
make intuitive sense so if it becomes
more expensive to get a mortgage that's
one form of borrowing
that makes a three hundred thousand
dollar house more expensive what i mean
by that is the house might be three
hundred thousand dollars either way but
if my mortgage on it is five and a
quarter percent instead of five percent
now that same three hundred thousand
dollar house is more expensive for me so
instead of spending three hundred
thousand on a house i might only spend
290. so that pushes down people's
budgets and it can push down housing
prices or at least slow down the
increase that's one component
uh vehicles car loans if car loans are
more expensive you might be less likely
to get a car loan or if you do you'll
get a cheaper car that pushes down on
price increases it discourages spending
and it can lower inflation now many
people will say but david it can also
slow down the economy well how how does
that work same principle one of the ways
that an economy grows is by people
investing in their own businesses
oftentimes people times people borrow to
invest in their business imagine that i
want to start a shoe business and i need
a factory and i need to borrow in order
to build that factory well if it's more
expensive to borrow i'm less likely to
do it or i'm less likely to borrow as
much meaning that instead of maybe
having four hundred thousand dollars to
build my factory which would go to
contractors and lawyers and insurance
and local businesses now i only have 300
000 so i'm slowing down economic growth
in that way it always is the case
that every one of these decisions is a
double-edged sword it is always the case
and so
very often you see
hyper-partisan discussions where we
shouldn't raise rates because that will
slow down the economy right but it could
also lower inflation which many of you
claim to want to do well we shouldn't
lower rates because it makes it too easy
to borrow
and therefore it will cause inflation
well yes that that's the that's the way
it works that's the double-edged sword
and the whole strategy the whole trick
of it is to keep these things uh in in
balance one other way in which raising
the funds rate discourages spending and
it can both lower inflation but slow
down the economy
if
if if anybody has a savings account i
was going to call it a high yield
savings account but there's very little
high yield about it many so-called
high-yield savings accounts over the
last couple of years at the most pay
about half a percent there's a number of
high-yield savings account where you can
earn 0.5
not a great incentive to just store your
money because it's lower than inflation
if the federal funds rate goes up half a
point
and thus high yield savings accounts pay
you more interest you might lean a
little more towards now i'm more okay
just saving the money and earning the
interest because the interest rate is a
little bit higher and instead of putting
that money into the economy you just
save it so that that's another aspect to
this every single one of these things
can have multiple effects and um that is
the importance of raising the federal
funds rate so we'll see what the impact
is
and uh we will see what forthcoming
additional increases there are and we've
been we've been warned to expect more i
hope that that's clear or at least
relatively simple
if it's not let me know and also let me
know if these types of segments are
useful as many of you know i'm a busy
person i don't always have the exact
correct nutritional plan for my meals
every single day and that's why i also
take a multivitamin and a couple of
supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75
high-quality vitamins and minerals and
my probiotics and it's all from whole
food sources i drink it in the morning i
know i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever spend time
planning when what time of day do i need
to take each one i just get it all with
one scoop you can put it in a smoothie
you can drink it straight it tastes
great and then i'm just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below